Jeff Passan ESPN baseball insider and
caught my attention apparently we're
gonna have baseball this year Jeff I'm
all ears
when are we having baseball it's a great
question answers I have no idea thanks
for coming on Jeff we'll talk to you
later great thank you so much as always
for having it's the latest plan you know
it's funny the people at major league
baseball well they don't like talking
about plans which is which is odd
because to go forward you need a plan
right you need a plan you need to have
it well laid out you need to execute it
you need to understand that they're
going to be flaws in it there are going
to be stumbles along the way no plan
goes according to plan and the fact that
they haven't committed to one yet it's
part of the process that they're going
through right now now I don't know if
this is the right approach to take you
know some would argue that you settle on
a plan early and you do everything you
can to make it work but I think that
what baseball sees right now is a
landscape that we don't understand we
have no idea what next week is going to
be like we have no idea what next month
is going to be like and because of that
their plan is to give themselves
flexibility and work on all the details
surrounding it that will no matter what
they choose whether it is going to a
biosphere in Arizona or going to a three
city hug plan where they have people
stationed in Phoenix metropolitan area
Dallas metropolitan area and Tampa st.
Pete area or or doing a five city plan
where you add Miami and Houston to the
mix no matter what they do they need to
have testing for example and they need
to have umpires in particular places and
they need all these logistical things
and that's the stuff they're trying to
take care of now so when they do figure
out what the best plan is they can
execute it all right but you say and
you're quoted there will be baseball in
2020
yes and you I do believe I do believe I
do believe that and I believe that
because I think all of the parties
involved are extremely motivated to have
baseball in some form or fashion I also
think that because maybe I'm trying to
be optimistic in this time where
optimism is in short supply but I'm not
allowing that optimism to guide me to
this place where baseball coming back is
not realistic I just you know I see the
country reopening and I know that we're
going to have stumbles along the way and
I understand that that's part of it but
I also think there's a recognition that
getting back to life like some form of
what we had before coronavirus is an
imperative and in that baseball is going
to be a part of that it's not going to
be a part of that with fans and all
likelihood but I think there is there's
very there's a very reasonable way that
games can be played under a variety of
circumstances and it's just a matter of
baseball figuring out which one suits
all of the parties involved us I'm also
wondering though how many games that
like is there a if we can't get this
many games in then we can't have a
season is there is there an amount that
they're they're looking at if you had
asked me that question two or three
weeks ago I would have said yes I think
there's a sort of a point at which the
season is not tenable I don't think
that's the case anymore
I think MLB right now and the players
are considering every possibility and
there was one in the column that I wrote
yesterday that I just sort of like
honestly when I was just sitting there I
dreamt up a tournament and and and it
was based on the fact that an official
said if you know something to the effect
of give us 60 days we could put out a
hell of a tournament and I think that
that's true is it you know would it be
like a championship season no but would
it be something that could be different
and compelling and
baseball like that's that right there
Dan I think is what people in the sport
are banking on at this point that some
baseball is better than no baseball and
and whatever format it takes we're just
going to embrace it you get one question
for the commissioner and he'll answer
what would it be
one's opening day good to talk to you
Jeff keep that optimistic column coming
by the way and I'm curious to hear your
take on this do you think the optimism
is is unwarranted and and do you think
there's gonna be baseball this year
I don't know Jeff and I just spent 15
minutes starting the show where I don't
like where we have these arbitrary dates
where we go hey
NBA facilities opening up May 1st and
then they come back and say now it's May
8th I think it's dangerous when we do
this with our sports leagues because it
trickles out to what we do every day I
think it gives us this full sense of hey
things are getting better here I don't
know that and I think when we we want
sports to come back it doesn't happen
magically just because we stomp our foot
and say I want my sports back it doesn't
work that way and I thought now the
Commissioner Adam Silver did the right
thing a month ago when he said I'm not
gonna put out any dates there and then
he comes out and puts out a date of May
first
now it's May 8 I don't know if the NBA
comes back I've always thought all along
that it wouldn't baseball I could think
maybe you get now a truncated 60 game
season college football I think is going
to be pushed back I think the NFL is
going to be pushed back a little bit I'm
being off I want to be optimistic I but
I also have to be realistic and that's
really if we still have a second before
a break let me let me come in here and
tell you why I think the the date thing
actually has been good I think it's I
think it has shown that these leagues
can be judicious if leagues were trying
to get back at all costs they would be
setting
extraordinarily aggressive dates and
trying to push for them they would be
bypassing Public Health protocols and
standards they wouldn't have a meeting
today with the White House and their
their public health experts that they
have hired the worst thing that could
possibly happen to any league is for it
to come back and have it fail and I
think we have to understand that that is
the great emergency break here that is
going to prevent them from coming back
before it's time can they push can they
talk about it can they give us hope can
they give us optimism is it false yeah
you know all those things are true but I
think when it's all said and done the
most important thing here is that the
decisions are made in concert with
health experts and and not for poor
reasons like profit like if we can get
to that point that's where I as a sports
consumer and as a human being feel good
about the way that this has been handled
I just don't like when we talk about
jump-starting the economy and we use
sports because fans aren't going to be
going to the games that's how you
jumpstart the economy in the world of
sports if we're gonna bring back sports
then bring it back don't bring it back
while we're pushing the envelope saying
we got to jumpstart the economy here
that's dangerous that's careless that's
reckless in my opinion I think that
sports can be part of it and and I think
we have to you know I think one thing we
have to understand now man is is just
how different the new normal is going to
be and how we have to adjust to these
very weird states of affairs where
people look at sports as something that
can jumpstart the economy I don't even
know if it's jump-start the economy so
much as it is bring some semblance of
normalcy back to life and it is a it is
a hard thing for anyone to do but Sports
has always been that very unifying
figure in this country and I think
that's why people want to look at it
because in a time of discomfort
what is sports if not comfort Jeff thank
you we'll talk soon pleasure is mine
damn there's nobody
Jeff Passan ESPN baseball insider